foreign
[Music]
if you've been prototyping with large
language models you might be wondering
if there's a way you can improve the
quality of responses Beyond just
handcrafting prompts so let's dive in
and look at what it takes to tune a
large language model and how to launch a
tuning job from vertex generative AI
Studio as a quick recap The Prompt is
your text input that you pass to the
model your prompt might look like an
instruction and maybe you add some
examples
then you send this text to the model to
get it to take on the behavior that you
want
prompt design allows for fast
experimentation and customization and
because you're not writing any
complicated code you don't need to be an
ml expert to get started but coming up
with prompts can be tricky small changes
in wording or word order can impact the
model results in ways that aren't
totally predictable and you can't really
fit all that many examples into a prompt
even when you do discover a good prompt
for your use case you might notice that
the quality of model responses isn't
totally consistent one thing we can do
to alleviate these issues is tune the
model
so what's tuning you ask well one
version you might be familiar with is
fine tuning
in this scenario we take a model that
has been pre-trained on a generic data
set
we make a copy of this model and then
using those learned weights as a
starting point we retrain the model on a
new domain-specific data set
this technique has been pretty effective
for lots of different use cases but when
we try to fine-tune llms we run into
some challenges llms are well as the
name suggests large so updating every
weight would take a very long training
job compound all of that computation
with the hassle and cost of now having
to serve this giant model and as a
result fine-tuning a large language
model might not be the best option for
you but there's an Innovative approach
to tuning called parameter efficient
tuning this is a super exciting research
area that aims to reduce the challenges
of fine-tuning llms by only training a
small subset of parameters these
parameters might be a subset of the
existing model parameters
or it could be an entirely new set of
parameters for example maybe you add on
some additional layers to the model or
an extra embedding to The Prompt
figuring out the optimal methodology is
an active area of research but the key
benefit here is that you're not having
to retrain the entire model and all of
its many weights parameter efficient
tuning can also make serving models
simpler in comparison to fine tuning
instead of having an entirely new model
you need to serve you just use the
existing base model and add on the
additional tune parameters
if you want to learn more about
parameter efficient tuning and some of
the different methods There's a summary
paper linked below for those who are
extra curious but if you just want to
get to building then let's jump into
generative AI studio and see how to kick
off a tuning job
from the language section of vertex
generative AI Studio select tuning to
create a tuned model we provide a name
then point to the local or cloud storage
location of your training data
parameter efficient tuning is ideally
suited for scenarios where you have
modest amounts of training data say
hundreds or maybe thousands of training
examples
your training data should be structured
as a supervised training data set in a
text to text format
each record or row and the data will
contain the input text in other words
The Prompt followed by the expected
output of the model
this means that the model can be tuned
for a task that can be modeled as a text
to text problem
after specifying the path to your data
set you can start the tuning job
and monitor the status in the cloud
console
when the tuning job completes you'll see
the tuned model and the vertex AI model
registry
and you can deploy it to an endpoint for
serving or test it out in generative AI
Studio
that's an overview of parameter
efficient tuning and tuning models and
vertex generative AI Studio check out
the links below to learn more about
generative AI on vertex and to learn
more about large language models thanks
for watching and definitely let us know
in the comments what you're building
with generative AI
foreign